we have been hearing
for months now that uh race
is a correlate of poor outcomes uh for
covent 19 right that uh
that and i did not pull up uh these
papers but i
believe that we have heard that there is
evidence across uh
many domains crest many geographic
domains that
um that people of color specifically
uh black people and latino people are
more likely to contract covid
and are also more likely to have worse
outcomes when they do contract it
and there's there's obviously a question
of why that might be
so let's take a step back and find some
some other things that we now understand
to be true
poor air quality is understood
to correlate with
increased contraction and worse outcomes
of covid
so here is a july 28
2020 uh intercept article zachary
uh you can pull up
which finds that um
i cannot find okay you can take it down
um quote from the paper quote from the
article that i couldn't find right there
when i pulled it up for you guys
respiratory illnesses are no stranger to
the latino communities who live around
california's largest lake the salton sea
asthma rates here are some of the
highest in california with air quality
routinely failing
to meet federal and state standards
thanks in part the state's omnipresent
water wars
the water in this desolate former
vacation destination is rapidly drying
up
salinating the lake and releasing
decades-old contaminants into the air
so there's a whole lot that we could say
about what the salton sea is you know it
was originally a desert flat that got
formed by accident when
the colorado river got dumped a bunch of
a bunch of water got dumped there
and it became briefly this vacation
destination
um but then something about a lot of
another water move
a lot of water being moved to san diego
i think basically began desalinating
or rather salinating the lake by
decreasing the water levels in the lake
so that you have these towns with names
like oasis and mecca
where um really no vacationers any
longer visit
or or live there and of course what you
have are
a lot of of latinos who are often
farm workers sometimes migrant farm
workers often not
who live there because housing is cheap
because it sucks to live there
right and so what we have is a finding
that
latinos living near the salton sea have
higher rates of covid
um and have worse outcomes when they get
covered but we
what we really have here is a as a class
issue right that uh you know i predict
that
anyone who is living in the salton sea
is going to have these higher rates of
asthma
and prolonged respiratory problems and
that when a respiratory virus shows up
of course they're going to be more
susceptible to it as well
similarly we have high population
density
being a predictor of uh bad outcomes in
covid so here's uh zach you want to put
this up just briefly
um a a fairly uh badly dud
article in willamette week out of
portland uh the title being people are
more likely to catch cove at east of
82nd avenue
that's where portland's housing is the
most overcrowded in this case the
headline is better than the article
because the article actually really
consistently conflates
uh race and class and and
doesn't doesn't grant that actually both
of those things are correlated
with um overcrowding so um
except in high density urban centers
where living in a high rise is actually
um sometimes an indicator of wealth we
know that being in overcrowded housing
conditions
is correlated with class and because of
historical
racism maybe modern racism but certainly
due to historical racism which
apparently irritates the cat no end
as it should it should um we have
uh people who have been um
oppressed in the historically oppressed
populations who are
who are more likely to be living in high
population density um
housing and so again we have you know
how how is it that we can tease apart
racing class we have a result uh that
people of color are more likely to be
getting coveted
and suffering worse when they do um but
is it true
that that is true even when you control
for class i don't know
i don't know uh and then finally we have
factory work
um factory work uh which of course
brings with both high population density
when you're in factories and low air
quality and
obviously is a correlate for class um
here's a story from the guardian
on july 11th oops la basque factories
shut down as hundreds of workers get
sick now this obviously brings in the
additional problem of now masks aren't
being made because
it's mask factories that are being shut
down but
the the point is that we have a number
of these things pointing in the same
direction
right that class um seems to be
a uh a predictor of
sorry for those listening and not
watching there's a cat on the screen on
the table now
class is certainly a predictor of bad
outcomes for kovid
but is is race separately from class i'm
not
i'm not sure that that's true and i
don't know that it's not true but
um i'm not sure so one more thing brett
before you start commenting as you
extract the cat without knocking over
our water uh we have a cdc report that
came out
just uh yesterday zach if you would show
this
hospitalization rates and
characteristics of children aged less
than 18 years
hospitalized with laboratory confirmed
covet 19
um in 14 states from march 1st july 25th
and one of the results of this report
one of the findings
they have they report is that indeed
specifically latino and black children
had higher cumulative rates of covid
associate hospitalizations
uh and uh and well well that that they
that they had worse outcomes than than
white kids
and this one this report i believe does
not attempt to
tease out whether or not that was true
if you would control for class as well
um i would just point out that there are
ways actually that what we
and i've said elsewhere i won't go into
it here but um
the term race is a problem because it's
not
it is a fiction but it is not entirely a
fiction it is
a social fiction built around something
that we might call population or lineage
and um that those things are real
biological phenomena whereas race is
polluted by politics
but in any case there are ways i think
that words
saying again i mean this is just
incredibly important population is a
real
concept that yes all populations pretty
much will have fuzzy boundaries both
temporally and spatially but that
doesn't make them
not real whereas race is like the
politicization
the politization is the situation it's
the weaponization
of yeah and maybe it was from the
beginning and maybe it wasn't i'm not i
don't know
um but it is it appears to be a
context-free ideology-free description
of populations but it of course is not
it is not and you can tell that because
um you know a one-drop rule
is obviously a political phenomenon not
a biological phenomenon
yeah but i would there's one fly in the
ointment here which is
what drives people to weaponize it is
a kind of racism to which humans are
prone
yeah and so it is your genes trying to
get you to advance their interests
you know against the values that most of
us would hold
that causes things like a one-drop rule
to emerge and we can talk about the
biological basis for that
another time but it's a complex story
race is simultaneously
a fiction it is a bastardization of
something biological
it is itself not a biological
description but the
the warping the distortion is driven
by a biological motivation that is not
honorable and
to which we should be responding and um
figuring out how to prevent it from
having hegemony but in any case
i would just point out there's a way
that race can play into this that has
everything to do with actual population
of origin
yes and nothing to do with racism
and i would just say that that has to do
with the fact that vitamin d has
consistently shown up
so we'll get as we're going there okay
well no i mean
all i would say is the simple
interaction
so the reason that some people have dark
skin
is because their ancestors come from a
place where the sun comes in through the
atmosphere more directly the closer you
are to the equator the more directly the
sun comes through the atmosphere the
less of it is absorbed on the way down
the sun's rays hit the earth more
perpendicularly and so go through less
atmosphere to get to the earth and so it
is
it you get you you you get more of it
for you standing in any one place get
more of it standing there
per hour or per year or whatever and the
point is uv light as we're about to
discuss
is extremely destructive stuff and so
melanin
is built-in sunscreen right rather than
sunscreen that you either wear
or slather on it is sunscreen that's
built into the skin and of course
people who tan i've never been very good
at it but people who tan
are you know ratcheting up in time their
production of the
this molecule to shield their their
basically feel their dna from the damage
that comes from uv light
but in any case that shield whatever it
is
whether it's a jacket or whether it's
melanin in your skin
interrupts the production of vitamin d
which is photosynthetically created in
our skin in response to sunlight and so
vitamin d for whatever reason has shown
up as a primary factor you will
you are less likely to get sick and you
are if you do get sick you are
likely to get much less sick if you have
proper levels of vitamin d rather than
are deficient
and so that can interact in just a
physiological way with different
populations the prediction of course of
that
being that populations will suffer in uh
in proportion to the degree of darkness
of their skin even individuals might be
able
you could see this pattern within
individuals darker people um
might be more affected so that would be
a non uh that has nothing to do with
racism right
but it has to do with has to do with
race but not with racism
and then this these findings that seem
to have to very much to do with class
um class correlates with race
100 due to historical racism but is it
due to modern racism
that is actually a hypothesis that needs
to be demonstrated right and
and um and no one appears to be testing
it we are all expected to simply accept
it
well and i would just point out that
this is you know i don't know if we're
going to get to
what two plus two might equal but um the
this is the tragic irony of this
um desire to unhook all of the
structures that we have
built and discovered to evaluate what
might be true the claim that these
things are all
weaponized and therefore none of them
are trustworthy as preposterous what you
want in this circumstance
is something called an anova you want an
analysis that tells you what
fraction of the difference in
susceptibility to covid or the degree
of symptoms that you have is due to
class
what if you control for class what
fraction of it is due to race
if you control for those things what
fraction of it is due to
the darkness of your skin what fraction
of it is due to zip code so the point is
all of these things have a contribution
that can be discovered you can't do it
perfectly but we have the tools the
bigger the sample
the better the tools work and we can
figure out how much of these things
are due to x y z factor
and ultimately there will be a factor
that has to do with modern racism is a
big
factor small factor we can predict but
um
and should we be trying to reduce modern
racism to xero of course
[Music]